[Music]
the Weinstein scandal continues to
deepen every day now
Oscar winners Angelina Jolie and Gweneth
Paltrow say they were both sexually
harassed by the movie mogul that's not
all
Weinstein phases newly revealed
allegations of rape as the list of stars
speaking out grows larger by the day
Paltrow tells the New York Times
Weinstein harassed her when she was 22
she had just signed up for a star-making
part in the movie Emma and was meeting
with him in his hotel room
she says Weinstein placed his hands on
her and suggested they go to his bedroom
for massages quote I was a kid I was
signed up I was petrified according to
The Times she refused his advances and
told her boyfriend at a time Brad Pitt
eg has learned that Pitt confronted
Weinstein and told him repeatedly that
it better never happen again
and Brad's ex Angelina Jolie also tells
the paper Weinstein made unwanted
advances to her in the late 90s in a
hotel room which she rejected quote I
had a bad experience with Harvey
Weinstein in my youth and as a result
chose never to work with him again
and warned others when they did and more
bombshells today The New Yorker
published a detailed report adding new
claims that Weinstein raped three women
including the actress hacia Argento
today she tweeted a scene from a movie
she wrote and directed which she says is
similar to what she experienced with the
Hollywood mogul in a statement this
morning Weinstein's rep said quote any
allegations of non-consensual sex are
unequivocally denied by mr. Weinstein
and his lawyer called previous New York
Times reporting quote saturated with
false and defamatory statements an Oscar
winner Mira Sorvino told The New Yorker
Weinstein sexually harassed her in 1995
while she was promoting the movie mighty
Aphrodite she spoke to KTLA this morning
it's a travesty that this sort of
behavior is normalized and accepted for
decades in this industry there was a
flood of condemnation today by
Weinstein's former colleagues George
Clooney called his actions
quote indefensible actress Jennifer
Lawrence said quote this kind of abuse
is inexcusable and absolutely upsetting
Ben Affleck called the behavior
completely unacceptable and Matt Damon
did a lengthy interview to deny that he
tried to kill a 2004 expose on Weinstein
saying quote I would never ever ever try
to kill a story like that well we don't
expect to hear any further from Harvey
Weinstein anytime soon his rep says
quote he has taken the time to focus on
his family on getting counseling and
rebuilding his life now Harvey has two
young children with his wife Georgina
Chapman of the popular Marquesa fashion
label
[Music]
you
[Music]